you'll know I love your work my name is
Charlie my question today is associated
with you as a scientist and how you've
evolved over time to deal with both
science itself and the ethics and morals
associated with science so I'll start
off with this quote so science can tell
you how to clone a Tyrannosaurus Rex
humanities can tell you why this might
be a bad idea so my question today is
whether or not you prefer to deal with
the morals and ethics associated with
scientific concepts or the exploration
and explanation of the concepts
themselves and which one engages you to
a greater extent Charlie this is a great
question but in mathematics you may have
run across the word integer and you know
may know the word integral and you may
know the word integral it's integral to
my outlook at whatever you what we want
is for everybody to be a complete person
with a complete point of view a complete
understanding of the process of science
which enables humankind to know nature
but also to have an appreciation for
what it means to be a member of the
tribe to be a human to be living here on
earth with other humans and other
species so we want you to have both an
appreciation for the process of science
and an appreciation for ethics or what
seems to be the best way to live the
best way to conduct yourself on earth
and especially in the human tribe so
with that said when it comes to ethics
I always pretty much always harken to
evolution and here's the extraordinary
claim and you can evaluate this Charlie
that not only is our size and shape the
number of fingers we have our eye color
or hair color skin color associated with
our our ancestors and the genes that
were passed to us through the process of
evolution but furthermore what we feel
is a result of evolution our ancestors
who were anti-social jerks got pushed
aside by the ones that were perhaps more
social and less jerky however you don't
want to be meek you want to have the
right level of aggression in the right
level of accommodation with your
fellow-creatures and when it comes to
ethics when you look at whatever scheme
you feel is most reasonable to pass your
genes on into the future that usually
leads to what we all consider ethical
behavior in the classic example and this
is not my fault don't come running to
meet charlie okay this is this is a
thought experiment charlie okay don't
bust my chops it's not a real thing the
house is on fire you have a chance to
either save your son or your grandson by
the rules of this thought experiment you
can't save both there's no you can't say
why find a fire hose and I call in the
Terminator and he can walk through
fright no you not know you pick your
grandson you will always pick the
grandson you will feel that because that
passes the genes farther into the future
if you're a guy if you're a woman you'll
pick whichever offspring is farthest in
the future it's the same thing so when
it comes to how you should treat other
people who are not part of your family
everybody who's a human is and somehow
is somehow related if you go far enough
back everybody is related troubling as
that may seem and so you this old thing
expressed as the golden rule rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
if you can do that Charlie I think you
will get through life as well or better
than anyone
carry on
you